chalmin bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors une aide
iranienne au venezuela qui risque de
relancer les tensions entre washington
et caracas
on sait que le gouvernement nicolás
maduro a annoncé que l'essai pétrolier
iranien serait escorté par l'armée c'est
un signal pour les états unis qu'il est
prêt à s'accrocher à la première corde
de pendu venu et donc c'est de bonne
guerre
il utilise les derniers stocks d'or de
la banque centrale du venezuela pour
acheter du pétrole l'aca pour acheter de
l'essence et du diesel plus tôt puisque
il se trouve incapable d'en produire ce
qui est quand même un paradoxe puisque
le venezuela et le sel détient les plus
grandes réserves mondiales de pétrole
comme le rappelait ils en sont au point
d'être obligé à d'importer de produits
raffinés de la part de l'iran l'iran
finalement est gagnant sur les deux
côtés dans ce sens qu'il est requis cote
un peu les états unis et il se fait
payer en espèces sonnantes et
trébuchantes
vous venez de le dire un le venezuela
possède les plus grandes réserves de
pétrole au monde sa production est en
chute libre
comment expliquez vous cela c'est en
partie à cause des sanctions qui sont
imposés aujourd'hui
non je dirais que le venezuela l'exemple
type pour moi de ce que j'appelle la
malédiction du pétrole à pétrole qui
n'aura apporté à ce peuple peut désastre
nuisent hervé une égalité alors c'était
c'est une longue histoire
c'était déjà le cas à l'époque où le
venezuela
comment c'est un peu avant même les
premiers chocs pétroliers
je rappelle toujours et c'est quand même
un symbole que la première boutique à
l'étranger que christian dior avait créé
dans nous sommes à la fin des années 50
au début de soirée
cet état karakash il y avait énormément
de richesse énormément d'inégalités
ainsi et c'est pour cela que lorsque
hugo chavez prend le pouvoir
illégalement d'abord puis légalement ça
a été plutôt dans le bon sens
malheureusement suite les vapeurs du
pétrole leur sont monté à la tête
et comme beaucoup d'autres pays
pétrolier au venezuela le pétrole rime
avec pauvreté avec corruption avec
captation des richesses par quelques
élites dans ce cas-là ce fait l'armée
alors tant qu'il y avait au goût de
chavez ça marche est encore un petit peu
puis le pétrole et est à 100 dollars le
baril aujourd'hui où on est à peine à 30
dollars le baril
nicolas maduro n'a manifestement pas les
mêmes capacités mais prisonnier d'une
petite oligarchie militaire qui a été
lentement soutenu par cuba et donc je
dirais que dans l'état où il est il a
pas beaucoup de portes vers lesquelles
allaient alors l'embargo américain
aggrave la chose mais les problèmes sont
beaucoup plus anciens à l'époque il y
avait dessus d'ailleurs une grève de
tous les cadres et des personnels de la
compagnie nationale pétrolière la paix
des bsa et le venezuela a perdu
énormément de capacité vous savez quand
vous mettez à la tête d' unique appel
d'une compagnie pétrolière des généraux
c'est pas forcément leur métier et la
production n'a fait que baisser lorsque
le pen a été créée simplement parce que
le pp créé il ya trois pays qui sont
l'arabie saoudite l'iran et le venezuela
qui produisent à peu près chaque cas 4
millions de barils/jour
aujourd'hui l'arabie saudite étape lui
des millions de barils/jour l'iran en
eau aurait des capacités de remonter
assez facilement à 4 millions de barils
jours ils sont bloqués par les problèmes
dans bardot et quand venezuela sans même
l'embargo ils ont produit je crois le
mois dernier si sous cette forme il
barils jours seulement
dernière question très rapidement c'est
que l'iran le venezuela sont deux pays
qui sont confrontés à des sanctions
américaines est ce que ces mesures
punitives ont favorisé justement une
entraide entre les deux pays mais je le
répète il n'y a pas d'entrée d'un fils
peu longue lui et aigle à l'iran ne met
pas le venezuela l'iran avant des
produits pétroliers au venezuela en
échange des dernières quantité d'or que
détenait la banque centrale du venezuela
puisque maduro une partie de ce stock
d'or étaient détenus à londres par la
banque d'angleterre
maduro vient de demander de le retirer
alors il ya toute une controverse pour
savoir qui tu le finalement le
propriétaire légal de cet or mais il ne
faut pas se faire d'illusions et je
pense pas que l'iran est une
particulière affection pour le régime
bolivarien
merci beaucoup en tout cas philippe
chalmin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
spécialiste des matières premières